[Musique]
amo suit la date prévue de 36 n'étant
pas répondu de quoi en gros mais tous un
peu d'argent et on vend des choses vous
voulez quoi
elle est le maintien et l'ordure les
affaires vintage qui ne m'était jamais
on n'a pas touché les autres joseph
avait souhaité chaussures ans dans
l'établissement vers quoi je vous invite
à me touche et me montre non mais je
vous ai fait quoi ça m'est mlcd moody's
élections c'est combien avoir fait ça
mais pour faire quoi ils viennent pour
faire quoi pour sauver la planète papa
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup fait ça pour la télé
à écouter apparemment c'est pour sauver
la planète
ah ok d'accord bon c'est quoi cette idée
en fait on va faire une très très grande
main en afrique
c'est bien les enfants au projet
au congrès rien du tout ça j'ai bien
réfléchir
si tout ça c'est vraiment sérieux leurs
projets
je mettrai pas notre petit partir tout
seul je partir avec lui
imposture et gauche
[Musique]
je me demande si t'es pas jaloux de clés
de notre fils son courage je te remercie
t'as rien
on cherchait des poubelles et des
couleurs différentes par le tri c'est
plus facile non oui et ça j'ai pris les
ampoules qui consomment moins aussi
c'est bien
[Musique]